quel est ton nom hazel allons regarder un
film je suis libre plus tard cette semaine pas moi
maintenant tu pourrais être un meurtrier à la hache il y a
toujours cette possibilité Fault in Our
Stars l'histoire d'amour de deux enfants atteints de
cancer mais ce n'est pas à propos du cancer c'est
plein de métaphores  et ils acceptent tous les deux
que ce sera leur seul et
dernier amour ils étaient juste vraiment magiques
ensemble je n'ai jamais rien vécu de
tel je suis content que ce soit Shailene
tu dois être ma grâce noisette et
j'espère qu'elle est contente  que je dois être votre
gussy deux sont si adorables nous sommes juste
amis
eh bien elle est je ne le suis pas c'est un processus très organique
nous tous nous avons tous vraiment cliqué la
chimie entre nous est si réelle
chaque jour nous venons juste de venir jouer
Je ne peux pas vous dire à quel point je suis reconnaissant de
votre petit apport
[Musique]